Microsoft revealed new enhancements and
color schemes for its Xbox design lab
controllers at e3 we customized one and
went ahead and ordered it how did it
turn out let's take a look the newly
updated controllers feature four new
color options desert tan Sierra brown
mineral blue and ink blue we went with a
ladder for the body of our design and
desert tan for joysticks bumpers
triggers and deep end Microsoft now
gives you metallic options for the
triggers and d-pad that cost three and
four dollars more respectively so we
added them to our cart for another six
bucks you can add rubberized grips so we
added that too finally to top it all off
we paid in an additional $10 to get a
GameSpot engraving at the base of the
controller the ink glue turned out a
little darker than we had expected but
we like the new rubberized grips in
metallic decals we're not convinced all
those new features are worth the total
$103 asking price though but it may
appeal to those who have spare cash just
burning a hole in their wallets what do
you think of our design let us know in
the comments below if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
for more thanks for watching
[Music]